Disney and Marvel's surprise re-release of
Avengers: Endgame is upon us, and it looks
as though the companies have a single goal
in mind: rake in enough money to make the
superhero ensemble the highest-grossing movie
of all time.
There's just one big, blue problem standing
between Endgame and that highly sought-after
top spot: Avatar.
"The Navi say that every person is born twice.
The second time is when you earn your place
among the people."
Directed by James Cameron, Avatar earned a
whopping $2.749 billion worldwide when it
launched in 2009.
The flick, a sci-fi epic starring Sam Worthington
as a former marine named Jake who travels
to Pandora and befriends the Na'vi people
went on to score even more money at the box
office when 20th Century Fox decided to re-release
it in 2010.
In its second theatrical outing, Avatar surpassed
Cameron's disaster romance epic Titanic to
become the biggest film in history based on
global revenue.
Avatar now stands tall atop a pile of cash
that amounts to $2.788 billion.
Avengers: Endgame, the culmination of over
10 years of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
brought to life by sibling filmmakers Joe
and Anthony Russo, quickly soared past the
$2 billion benchmark at the box office after
its debut.
During its initial theatrical release that
officially began on April 26, Endgame effortlessly
beat out Titanic, which took home $2.187 billion
worldwide, to become the second best-grossing
movie in cinematic history.
"Are you serious?"
"Yeah."
"Yes!
Haha!"
Though Endgame's commercial success slowly
tapered off following its massive opening,
the film currently posts a staggering $2.751
billion in global revenue, with screenings
still happening as of Monday, June 24th.
Clearly, Avatar and Avengers: Endgame are
neck and neck.
The latter needs roughly $37 million more
in global profits to push past the former
and be crowned as the highest-earning movie
ever.
But is that possible?
Can Endgame really make nearly $40 million
worldwide when Disney and Marvel kick off
the re-release on Friday, June 28th?
"If we do this, how do we know it's gonna
end any differently than it did before?"
It seems tough, but not impossible.
When Fox put Avatar back in theaters a year
after its original release, showing off nine
minutes of never-before-seen footage that
cost more than $1 million per minute to produce,
the film took home just over $33 million globally.
Accounting for the rise in ticket prices,
from an average $7.89 per ticket in 2010 to
an average $9.01 per ticket in 2019 according
to Box Office Mojo, the Avatar re-release
would have made about $37.7 million had it
been rolled out this year.
There's arguably a much bigger market for
Avengers: Endgame than there was for Avatar,
given the film's mass appeal and diehard fanbase.
That will certainly factor into how much money
the Endgame re-release pulls in, as its second
round of success is largely down to how many
people head out to theaters to see the new
version of the movie.
The extra content included in the re-release
of Avengers: Endgame should draw viewers back
in, even those who have already watched the
super-sized superhero movie several times.
Marvel Studios president Kevin Feige clarified
in an interview with Screen Rant when news
of the re-release went public that the new
version of the movie isn't an alternate or
extended cut; instead, it features extra footage
that's tacked onto the end of the three-hour
film fans have likely already seen before.
Feige told Screen Rant:
"[It's] not an extended cut, but there will
be a version going into theaters with a bit
of a marketing push with a few new things
at the end of the movie.
If you stay and watch the movie, after the
credits, there'll be a deleted scene, a little
tribute, and a few surprises."
"Trust me, true believer…Trust me — "
Yup, it's assumed that the tribute Feige spoke
of is one dedicated to Marvel Comics maestro
Stan Lee, who passed away at the age of 95
in November 2018.
The mystery surrounding the deleted scene
and the "surprises" that await fans after
the credits roll still remains, and Marvel
is probably banking on that intrigue translating
into ticket sales.
Normally, curiosity kills the cat, but in
this case, it could be the key to Avengers:
Endgame shattering the biggest movie record
there is.
The Avengers: Endgame re-release is said to
begin on Friday, June 28th.
It's unclear how long the new version will
stay in theaters.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.